[Musique]
alors soyez le ou la bienvenue à votre
tam-tam canada du 28 mai bonjour tout le
monde
bonjour bonjour fantastique moi je
reviens de vacances vous vous apprêtez
tous à partir en vacances c'est le bon
moment comme ça de s'échanger des
souvenirs des sourires et de parler de
la qualité de vie qui est plus rien vous
qui revenait déjà qu'un seul ou qui sont
cinq ans soit un peu pâlotte non c'est
vous qui n'êtes pas là dedans moi je
suis très bon en amérindien aujourd'hui
mais bientôt ce retrait 13
latino-américain vous tous partent en
vacances quand exactement
à la fin du mois de juin vous pas le
martinez fin du mois de juin et puis
j'ai pu c'est les vacances
moi je vous vends une journée de
vacances de son art prochain et puis
marie claude simard est également avec
notre second semestre à l'émission
bonjour marie claude beaujour vous venez
de vous joindre à notre équipe ya deux
mois environ
les vacances donc attendre un peu j'ai
pris une journée déjà permis de me
ressourcer le ch en pleine forme notre
thème cette semaine c'est quel est le
secret du bien-être des canadiens de la
qualité de vie des canadiens puisque
sondage après sondage dans le monde pas
juste nous qui faisons une leçon dont
nous mêmes c'est le mort lancée qui nous
sommes et il découvre que ces canadiens
après tout ils sont des êtres incroyable
sont toujours heureux presque toujours
qualité de vie toujours au sommet dans
les six premiers saints premier puis
aussi le bonheur là se voyait pas la
quitter vise une chose le bonheur le
bonheur de vivre est très élevé
notamment dans une de nos dix provinces
canadiennes on verra laquelle plus tard
on est des gens qui nous saluent déjà
c'est un tel
adib et pratique adil est en congé
pendant beaucoup de moi parce que c'est
pas des congés pour l'été c'est un congé
de maternité
quel jour doit au moins c'était au money
ou à fin avril
fabbrica petite fille je connais sont
juste passées à dire que je le dise
[Rires]
alors en attendant la réponse je vais
vous me tourner vers palma cette semaine
mais vous lancer le bal de l'émission on
a été repêché dans nos archives que nous
mêmes mais ce trou noir notre nos gens
qui sont sur la terre ne peuvent les
consulter
suivez-nous suiveux très intelligent
vous avez un reportage au moins de
novembre dernier sur les citoyens
canadiens en se demandant c'est bien
beau de voir ça de loin le canada
vouloir émigrer mais ce qui fait
vraiment bon vivre au canada vous basez
vous aurez fait votre réflexion votre
article sur des données de l' ocde
exactement le cd a dit dans son dernier
rapport que les canadiens sont parmi les
plus heureux de ce monde par mais il y a
quelques quelques détails allez vérifier
au niveau de chiffre
parce que au canada selon selon de céder
malgré ses bonnes notes moyennes en ce
qui concerne le bien-être la richesse
est des plus simples de concentrés chez
les millionnaires
le revenu moyenne des 10 % des plus
riches canadiens et 8 points 6 fois plus
élevés que les 10% qui gagnent le moins
donc c'est à dire il y à beaucoup d et l
adema - ca - des riches mais quiconque
qui qui qui tiennent beaucoup plus
d'argent et plus en plus de gens qui ont
plus de difficultés à moi le fait de
même qu'un dessert vous etes unis au
royaume uni en france ou si j'imagine
j'imagine et existe également ghanam est
un peu moins élevé la com com tendance
peu moins forts comme tendance mais ça
fait partie du du malin ce qu'on ressent
canada par rapport au bien-être en
lançant - biais parce qu'on sent qu'on
gagne pas notre richesse ne s'accroît
pas aussi rapidement que celle des plus
riches est ce qu'on peut me résumer
comme ça d'affaires mais c'est un fait
ce qu'on peut dire par rapport à ce
rapport là ce que les canadiens il y a
des plus simples des gens qui n'arrivent
pas à se rendre au niveau de vie et
moyens adéquats satisfait st et puis il
y avait plus un il ya même des mots - à
moins de personnes qui ont le plat la
plus grande quantité d'argent qui est
générée d'un pays très bien on va aller
une vidéo dans un instant à les voir
comment ça se passe dans la réalité pour
les gens qui essaient de joindre les
deux bouts canada qui se trouve dans un
environnement enchanteur mais qui trouve
que c'est difficile au plan économique
jeu-questionnaire numéro un de la
semaine d'imaginer lumières partout j'ai
promis d'en apporter un jour c'est un
budget encore une fois alors vous
parliez de des gens les plus riches
voici une autre façon de présenter le
problème au canada de la disparité les
86 personnes les plus riches au canada
ou 0,000 2% de la population ne viennent
de plus en plus est sur un autre rapport
en fait part récemment au canada il le
total de leurs richesses correspond au
total de la richesse de combien de
millions de canadiens nous sommes 36
millions alors des 86 personnes les plus
riches ont les revenus les deux combien
de millions de canadiens mais les 20
millions ou 20 millions c'est des gens
riches richesse
margot 5 millions oui c'est beaucoup
plus modeste toujours comme ça jeudi 7
mai à 7 millions hors éléments des
radicaux ya pauvres mais les branchies
bâti pascal a répondu oh non je suis
inquiet il n'y a pas répondu ou s'ils
veulent qu'on vise les noms mais asie et
oui c'est une beau défi et vous dit
bonjour et l'humain qu'elle n'a pas
encore écouté qu'on veut dire le nom de
la petite petite là tout de suite parce
que vous nous faites
non madame à la fin de l'émission voici
la réponse on attend paradis a toujours
et puis la qpc aux sages ont évidemment
alors la réponse et 11,4 millions de
quartier âgés c'est moi qui étais même
la plus proche c'est vrai cette mission
c'était la page
mais oui vous étiez à 13 millions de
distance mais aussi dans la sélection de
notre question parce que là où il ya des
perdants dans le jeu questionnaire notre
occasion de vous racheter index de
qualité de vie dans le monde trois
villes canadiennes dans le top-5
lesquels paloma
halifax halifax une des cinq villes dans
le monde n'est plus où on est on est ni
plus heureux c'est sage pour vous et non
couverts découverte des trois villes les
plus lus ou la qualité de vie la
meilleure selon un récent et x10
international marie-claude le la ville
de québec
lavez le québec à belleville caisse
belle ville mais non c'est un saint mais
quand même la ville des jeunes non tout
à fait un festin leur apporte quelques
lots cd a publié l'année dernière le
nunavut calquella l'une des plus petites
régions de l'oscd par sa population se
situe parmi les plus dans les plus
belles barres en joli tir le plus bas en
ce qui concerne la sécurité la santé
l'emploi et l'engagement civique
donc non ne n'y mets route le territoire
du nunavut au canada et toronto toronto
ont cherché à l'identité des trois ans
non
c'est extraordinairement non je trouve
pas je comprends pas ottawa non la
capitale canadienne est loin de l'autre
aux tortionnaires aliphat non il le dire
c'est qu'on va rester dans l'ouest
canadien on parlait donc de cette grande
ville 20 couverts toujours première sous
la lumière dans le peloton des villes
internationales ce qui coûte très cher
d'y habiter j'ai des amis qui y viennent
de passer ici au québec lille veut
déménager les gens il est revenu moyen
que me 40000 les deux travaillent
impossible de s'avancer dans la ville
ont maintenant leurs enfants ils veulent
en avoir un deuxième ce ne sera pas
possible et pons pense maintenant à
venir au québec ou en ontario alors on
va aller voir une de ces résidentes à
vancouver qui pensaient que vancouver
c'était le mirage et c'était bien le cas
voici ce qu'elle raconte elle se décrit
dans ce reportage on va apprendre
beaucoup à son sujet annabelle bernard
est une ex résident de vancouver qui a
trouvé un meilleur équilibre sur elle en
s'installant dans une ville voisine à
une cinquantaine de kilomètres victoria
demande d'apparaître réalisé que les
gens tout ce que vous le faire c'est
aller au restaurant à aller voir des
spectacles
c'est des choses qui coûtent la relance
après quelques mois pour pouvoir jeter
si j'étais assez heureux d'être là aussi
car c'est devenu ce temps de trouver un
emploi des séries se développer en
réseau pour pour trouver un emploi j'ai
réalisé que les dames en dessous de ce
côté-ci nancy était assez assez élevé
s'il y avait comme un il y avait pas de
train pas de considération pour le fait
qu est ce qu on en soit on essaie
thermale assez d'argent pour aller
manger au restaurant profond par ce même
si jamais de trouver un emploi qui
paient plus que on parle de 40 m $ par
année encore
non j'ai trouvé il y avait un manque
dans le milieu pour quelqu'un sur elle
dans la classe moyenne qui ressort une
verge qui va commencer dans une
profession
vous voulez entendre cette entrevue le
lac en entrevue plusieurs minutes vous
allez sur le site de tam-tam canadien
cette semaine
et puis autre chose deux réponses à des
questions des jeux au jeu-questionnaire
16,5 millions c'est la réponse de radis
la richesse de 86 canadien correspond à
combien de millions canadiens
et puis le nom de la jeune fille miranda
merron confidentiels a dit que c'était
confidentiel mais personne malade
oui je viens de le dire alors voilà
c'est fait c'est fait je viens de l'été
pas j'écoute est pas comme tu as parlé
je t'appelle de faire autre chose alors
leur falloir écrire une lettre d'excusés
a dit je m'excuse
alors c'est avec grande tristesse que je
vous présente la question tant d'atouts
écoute cette semaine comment je vois la
garonne message aussi des malik à mr mcc
et nos équipes d pakistan pinault dit
bon job l'hybride y aura des merci
beaucoup de mots bonjour de très loin
comme ça un autre bon jour de très loin
en réponse à notre question tout en
écoute cette semaine
on rappelle la question et on donne la
réponse varie corde alors la question
était travaillez vous pour vivre où
vivez-vous pour travailler voilà alors
nous avons reçu une très belle réponse
de monsieur kouassi woods a donné au
togo alors il nous dit normalement le
premier sens du travail c'est de le
faire pour vivre sa vie mais ce n'est
pas le cas souvent chez nous en afrique
le travail est un devoir car sans
travailler on n'est pas respecté et on
sera incapable de s'affermir ou de se
marier tout africain a une mission à
accomplir sur cette terre dont convient
pour travailler et faire bénéficier le
fruit de ce travail à d'autres
générations conclusion tu travailles à
la fois pour toi et pour la famille ce
n'est pas comme en occident où on
travaille
la famille réduite au père la mère les
enfants seulement mon dieu et on
s'entend ça nous permet ici de
s'exprimer personnellement mais pas
tellement longtemps
on fait attention à ne pas oublier de
secrets allemands
alors est-ce que vous traitiez pour
vivre vous vivez pour travailler réponse
j'aime beaucoup mon travail j'aime
beaucoup mon travail donc que c'est un
peu des deux gg de travail pour vous oui
parce que j'ai besoin de l'argent
effectivement j'ai des enfants j'ai une
famille mais j'aime beaucoup ce que je
sais bon alors monsieur gimeno oui la
question
non non je vais jouer en fait c'est plus
ou moins la même chose en fait
ouais je fais c'est que j'aime mais
quand même il faut faire beaucoup
d'efforts parce que ces chars vivre ici
c'est cher un prix vraiment rien c'est
cher c'est pas mal là intense les
activités surtout et puis tu veux pas
que des enfants soient toujours à la
maison il faut qu'ils fassent des choses
à la la le les calculs c'est un calcul
faut faire faut le faire pendant des
années en passant si je m'offre ceci
comme un petit plaisir personnel
qu'est-ce que ça allait à mes enfants
c'est toujours cela factures qu'ils vont
gagner il faut qu'il gagne parce que
nous c'est moins important
à la longue ça use une personne
marie-claude vos enfants ils ont quel
âge aujourd'hui 27 25 et 22 bon est-ce
qui vous demande encore des sous sans
pendant l'été n'a pas cédé
mais oui moi je vais être honnête je
travaille pour vivre travailler pour lui
et puis évidemment si j'étais
indépendant de fortune je ne
travaillerai pas ben somnolent même
qu'un bon petit jeu là peut-être
exactement la même chose
c'est à dire j'aime ce que je fais mais
massa revient peu ce qu'on fait mais je
le ferai à mon rythme non mais sans les
y à revenir avec une amie
on va avoir la chance d'avoir la loto
par exxon est ce qu'on fait moi je dis
j'ai continué à travailler mais
en faisant de travail bénévole jeu
j'aime bien faire ça mais j'ai pas le
temps pour le faire
si j'aurai le temps parce que j'ai pas
besoin de travailler pour avoir de
l'argent peut-être ma vie ça c'est
vraiment travaillé pour les eaux moi je
rêve de faire le même métier mais il est
à la retraite donc de prendre mes
propres décisions sans influence
extérieure de détail les influences
extérieures rien sur les rythmes j'ai
choisi ça va trop vite là oui ça va vite
le travail c'est la production nous il
faut faire tu entames en 30 minutes à
cause des péchés
on va aller à quelque chose d'amusant
même les gens à vancouver qui doivent
travailler fort pour pouvoir rester là
sur place pays l'appartement notamment
c'est ça qui coûte très très cher là-bas
c'est une cellule c'est la deuxième vie
au monde je pense ou la première est le
plus cher roman la présente comme il se
bat à chaque fois dans une vidéo
inspirée de celle de la chanson happy du
musicien américain fair winds ya un
couple qui s'est installé au canada il
ya six ans qui a décidé de faire le tour
de leur ami tout ce travail pour la
plupart et ils nous offrent ce moment
détente tout à fait canadien inspiré par
des nouveaux canadiens pour montrer à
quel point ils aiment ils ont le goût de
vivre
le bien-être de vivre canadien le voici
le voilà
[Musique]
vous inviter au québec ce
cliquez berckois sont plus heureux non
seulement les migrants mais les
québécois sont plus heureux que
l'ensemble des canadiens
non non je ne crois pas pensé pour vous
non et dans les faits les québécois
lorsqu'on leur pose la question des oui
j'ai pas je suis juge une belle joie de
vivre
ils disent pas ma joie vivait plus
grande que celle des anglophones pas
comme ça qu'on pose est que non mais
lorsqu'on leur pose la question les
canadiens etes-vous de bonne humeur
avait boudé les francophones du québec
où les québécois répondent davantage oui
à cette question là c'est la grande
différence et sonores ne sont en effet
en tout cas on l'a cru zèle à faire dans
un long reportage voici un extrait est
ce que nous sommes prêts et aux ça c'est
une des hypothèses les plus souvent un
soulevé effectivement le québec c'est
l'endroit en amérique du nord où les
inégalités connaît mais sur les points
moins prononcé donc comme partout
ailleurs le fossé entre les riches et
les pauvres s'est creusée ici mais moins
qu'ailleurs
la journaliste nous annie mercier du
magazine québécois l'actualité a publié
un article sous le titre le gène du
bonheur est-il québécois ça c'est
considéré comme une source de bonheur le
bonheur dont je parle dans ce texte le
oui le côté joie de vivre émotions
positives
rires et tout ça c'est que quand on vous
pose la question est-ce que vous avez
une bonne vie satisfait de votre vie est
ce que votre vie se rapproche de l'idéal
pour vous les québécois répondent avec
des scores plus élevés que dans le reste
du canada y est plus élevé que presque
partout ailleurs dans le monde donc au
québec c'est ça qu'on a choisi en inde
et des institutions collectives des
valeurs collectiviste dans nos
institutions qui sont plus prononcées ce
qui est justement un papier de
statistique canada qui m'ont tellement
fasciné qui est paru l'année dernière où
on ne mesure et l'indicé de bonheur des
immigrants au canada qui sont ici depuis
dix ans et on les a comparées avec l'
indice de bonheur de leur pays et qui en
dit long
'l'indice de bonheur des immigrants
rattrape celui du canada en disant c'est
comme s'ils avaient quelque chose de
contagieux puisque nous c'est ce qui m'a
fasciné lancé ses recherches le sait que
on parle souvent du bonheur comme
quelque chose qu'on cultive
individuellement puis la pensée positive
et puis quelque chose qu'on sur quoi on
peut agir nous mêmes en faisant des
efforts individuels et le bonheur c'est
quelque chose qui collectif qui est
contagieux
[Musique]